[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a korean fantasy film
called the miracle spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
[Music]
the story surrounds a pair of opposite
twins sue me and rena sumi is shy and
likes to spend time locked up in her
room she is also overweight and has no
self-confidence as a hobby she sings on
live streams under the name sexy diva
over the years she has accumulated many
fans and followers but no one has ever
seen her face every time she goes live
the comments assume how pretty she must
be but sumi knows that if she shows her
face her popularity will rapidly decline
in contrast her sister rena lives the
dream of every young korean girl she is
the visual of a popular girl group
miracle girls she is signed to a label
and has millions of fans worldwide known
for her beauty and dance rina hardly
knows how to sing still she is the most
popular member of the group her
bandmates do not like her because she is
arrogant and rude one day their manager
informs them that rena has been called
to film a commercial video with a
popular male singer heisiong the other
girls are disappointed since rena gets
more opportunities than them even though
they are much better singers later that
day a couple of reporters come to the
girl's home to interview rena's family
however rina asks sumi to stay in her
room during the interview ashamed of her
looks when asked if she has any siblings
rina claims that her elder sister
studies abroad and is rarely home sumi
hates her sister because of her
unlikable personality despite being
twins they do not share anything about
their lives with each other and are
always arguing one thing that sumi
despises more than her sister is her
school her classmates bully her so much
that she always keeps a count of the
days left to graduate unfortunately for
her the group of bullies also has a
popular guy named gyosyak who she is
madly in love with last year around the
same time sumi had decided to confess
her feelings to gyosiak and bought him a
gift but the bullies caught her with it
and read the love letter out loud sumi
still hasn't gotten over the
embarrassment of being rejected in front
of everyone but her feelings for gyoz
haven't changed somewhere else rena goes
to the set of the commercial and meets a
fellow idol hey siong he is even more
arrogant than rena and likes to think of
himself as a musician more than an
entertainer knowing that rina is only
famous for her looks he is extremely
rude to her rena acts as the director
asks her to but to heiseng the concept
of the commercial sounds dumb he refuses
to take part in it and leaves his
manager to do the damage control because
of his pickiness rina is also removed
from the commercial she returns home
crying and cursing at him meanwhile sumi
is hanging out in their front yard with
their family dog when she isn't looking
it runs outside the house and disappears
sumi spends the entire day looking for
it and finds an older woman unconscious
on the ground she takes it upon herself
to carry the poor woman to her house
impressed by her kindness the woman
brings her inside and reveals that she
is a tarot reader on being asked to pick
a tarot card sumi chooses the rarest one
of them all according to the woman it is
supposed to grant her a wish although
skeptical sumi thinks of exchanging
lives with her sister but then she
changes her mind and asks for the
ability to never gain weight the woman
gives her a necklace as a present before
seeing her off while returning home with
her dog sumi suddenly passes out at the
same time rena who is in the middle of a
dance rehearsal also falls unconscious
when the sisters wake up they are by
each other's beds in a hospital
strangely enough their mother calls them
by different names confused they look at
each other and are shocked to see that
they have somehow exchanged their bodies
they immediately run outside and hit
their heads with a rock trying to switch
back but the stupid idea doesn't work
while brainstorming other plans sumi's
eyes land upon the necklace the tarot
reader gave her earlier she remembers
that she had subconsciously asked to
exchange lives with her sister and
rushes to the lady's house on reaching
the place they find out that the lady
has gone on a vacation and won't return
for a month the news is devastating for
both sisters who will now have to live
as the person they hate the most for the
next month to adjust to their new lives
they tell each other the do's and don'ts
of their day-to-day life sumi is asked
to be rude to everyone eat less and
practice the dance that their girl group
has been rehearsing but rena only has to
exist and be quiet to be like her sister
the following day they wear each other's
clothes exchange phones and get ready
for the day rina goes to school eating a
box of snacks she would have never eaten
in her previous body she is not worried
about being switched and considers it as
a free one-month vacation from her
usually busy lifestyle that is until a
group of bullies stops her gyosioc
snatches the box and makes fun of her
for liking him rena wants to teach them
all a lesson but remembers that sumi
would never do something like that and
keeps quiet meanwhile sumi goes to the
company for a final rehearsal of their
comeback show being the most popular one
in the group she is given the prettiest
clothes and first priority however when
it is time to perform she gets nervous
and messes up the dance hai siong who is
watching the performance laughs at her
lack of talent after the rehearsals they
will have to perform live nervousness
gets the best of sue me and she breaks
down crying in the bathroom she holds
the necklace and wishes to do her best
in the final performance lo and behold
when she finally has to perform she
doesn't forget a single step however the
main vocalist and her rival forget the
lyrics in the middle of the live
broadcast to help her sumi sings in her
place and steals the show even hai siong
is surprised to hear her actually sing
well after the show she accidentally
falls into his arms unlike rena sumi is
mesmerized by his beauty he puts her
down before going to the stage and
performing a song while sumi stares at
him in endearment at home rena is mad
that sumi sang well because after going
back to her body people will expect her
to do the same sumi promises to do her
worst the next time but then hai siong
texts her asking her to record a duet
with him rina remembers him being
arrogant the last time and wants sumi to
do her best and teach him a lesson at
school rena discovers sumi's journal and
reads it she soon finds out what her
sister goes through on a daily basis due
to the bullies the next time she bumps
into them she makes sure to insult one
of the girls makeup when the girl tries
to slap her rina restricts her hand
surprising everyone gyosiak comes
forward to humiliate her for liking him
for the hundredth time but rena in turn
calls him ugly and walks away he is left
stunned by the sudden personality change
and even finds it attractive humans are
so weird at the same time in the company
hai siang texts sue me to come to the
rooftop he apologizes for being rude to
her during the commercial and discusses
what song they should do at they seem to
have similar taste in music which makes
it easier to choose in the end hai siong
pulls her into an embrace asking her out
on a date in the following scene the
couple is in the studio mixing and
recording the song while listening to
the end result they end up kissing at
home the sisters sit down to talk about
their day since both of them did things
the other one wouldn't approve of they
lie to each other rina is distressed
that they still have 15 days to switch
their bodies but sue me has started
falling in love with hai siong and
doesn't feel like changing before going
to sleep she wishes that the tarot
reader never comes back from vacation
starting the next day she meets heiseng
on the rooftop every chance she gets she
enjoys the little time they have
together to the fullest meanwhile rena
continues reading sumi's journal a
flashback shows us that sumi had gone
for several musical show auditions she
was recognized for her talent but only
during blind auditions many directors
would bluntly call her names and dismiss
her talent because of her looks this
makes rena realize how unfair the world
is to the so-called ugly people her
classmates who usually bully her are
dancing to her song during recess when
rena laughs at them they challenge her
to do the same she surprises everyone by
performing better than all of them
gyosyak starts looking at her
differently after the incident the next
day sumi is using hai siong's computer
when she finds out that he watches her
singing live streams it gives her hope
that he might like her even when she
goes back to her normal body at the same
time rena is going through sumi's
computer she finds the sexy diva live
stream channel and accidentally starts a
stream with her face in front of the
webcam several comments flood in making
fun of her looks and she loses many of
her subscribers at night sumi cries
herself to sleep wishing to the necklace
that everyone forgets about the live
stream the following morning the live
stream is gone and no one is talking
about it almost as if it never existed
even rena doesn't remember going live
sue me figures out that the necklace is
not ordinary it has been granting all of
her wishes until now throughout the day
she tests the power of the necklace and
the wish comes true every time but she
also realizes that every time she is
granted a wish someone in her life
suffers the consequences like when she
asks for the food of her choice hai
siong's new song is accused of
plagiarism how the hell did she connect
the dots on that one similarly when he
messes up a live performance she wishes
for him to pick it right up the wish is
granted but a crew member is severely
injured as a result the next day geocock
locks himself in a studio saddened by
the plagiarism scandal sumi goes to meet
him and the two finish recording their
duet song together in the following
scene rina is excited because the 30
days are finally over the sisters go to
the tarot reader's house but see that
she still has not returned sue me thinks
that it's because she once unknowingly
wished for her never to return she yet
again makes a wish this time for the
reader to be back soon as a consequence
of the wish a dating rumor about her and
heisiong is spread in the media rina
finds out about the rumor and is furious
they get into a fistfight in the middle
of a parking lot and have to be
separated by heiseiong he pushes rena to
the ground telling her to stay away
however the gesture makes sumi believe
that he is only in love with rena's
pretty face the next day sumi visits the
tarot reader again and finds out from
her daughter that she passed away
because of a disease the girl also
reveals that to reverse a wish one must
hold the necklace and genuinely wish for
them to switch back to their bodies if
either of the girls does not actually
mean it the wish won't be granted on
finally finding a way to go back rena is
overjoyed but the same cannot be said
for sumi seeing that her sister is
bothered rina reveals that heiseng used
to hate her when she was in her own body
this means currently he is not in love
with rina's face but with sumi's
personality following the conversation
the girls make a wish as the tarot
reader has told but nothing changes then
the following day sumi and rina meet in
front of the company for work rena is
about to be hit by a car but sumi puts
her life in danger and saves her when
they wake up in the hospital they have
switched back to their original bodies
the doctor who is in charge of them
looks exactly like the tarot reader she
explains that sumi is the elder sister
and the protector of the younger one
since she fulfilled her purpose by
saving rena from the accident they were
able to switch back in the following
scene rina breaks up with hai siong
claiming that she doesn't want to lose
brand deals by being seen with him in
reality dating her sister's love is
unacceptable to her the bully gyosiak
also apologizes to sue me and expresses
that he has started to like her but she
rejects him since she is in love with
hai siong and because yoshiak is a simp
a few weeks later hai siong organizes a
musical audition rina brings the forms
to sue me encouraging her to participate
sumi gathers enough courage to go to the
audition mostly because she wants to
look at hai siong one more time she
sings the song they do edit together and
impresses everyone in the last scene we
see sumi and hai siong recording a song
together indicating that she got
selected in the audition
note that we never heard about the sexy
diva live stream again so i'd say the
moral of this story is to ignore toxic
internet comments subscribe for more
videos like this turn on the
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching